foreign
what's up Nico
good morning Dr John good morning Nico
what's up
well I have a problem that I've sought
resources for and basically the advice I
found on the internet is that the issue
I'm having makes me a wuss so I figured
I'd reach out to you and see if maybe
you could give me a little better advice
you were like I know it was I'll call
him well done Nico well done so what's
up man what's what's this problem you
got
well so
by the way never go to the Internet dude
thank you there you go I had to learn
that one the hard way go to random
podcasters way safer way safer all right
so what's up my wife speaks pretty
highly of you so I I figured that was a
good place to start you're a wise man
listening to your wise wife well done
okay so what's up
abused by my stepmother verbally
emotionally and physically thankfully
not sexually
um hold on hold on hold on hold on stop
you right there I'm gonna stop you
through this whole thing is that cool
yeah okay
there is no thankfully here
okay okay
it's easy to pass along to say hey it
was emotional it was physical it was
psychological but it wasn't this as
though there's levels here
okay I want you to sit in the hell that
was your childhood
and don't say yeah but somebody else got
this and somebody else got that we're
not gonna do that we're gonna let it
ride cool
okay all right we're in it now we're in
it your stepmother abused you
evil person tell me more yeah all right
well so she was my primary caretaker and
parental figure my dad worked a lot
we're talking gone for weeks come home
for a few days gone again
and so she was my primary person and
and I didn't really think much of it as
a kid it was just that was my normal but
then they got divorced when I was
getting ready to enter eighth grade
and
things happened I I didn't know about it
at the time but I had issues with women
especially when they would show any
emotion besides happiness I would shut
down
and I
only had a couple of relationships
through High School nothing really
serious and then after high school
I again didn't realize it at the time
but looking back on I kind of avoided
interacting much with women like
jumped into male dominated professions
and
basically became my father working all
the time and then
about two years ago
um
my wife who was one of the couple
relationships I did have in high school
she was my childhood sweetheart uh
we we reconnected after more than a
decade and
ended up getting married and we actually
just on Valentine's Day had had a
daughter congratulations man
thank you
but through the course of our marriage
there's been a couple incidents where my
wife has had tension or conflict with
another woman
and I didn't defend her
and
basically I just kind of shut down and
I didn't stand up to the other woman and
it's it's a thing that I again at the
time didn't notice until we talked about
it and she pointed out to me that
she doesn't feel safe because I don't
defend her and it's interesting and it's
caused a lot of reflection on me because
if it was a dude no question I'm a
pretty big dude I used to fight like I
was I was a fighter it wasn't great I
was eight and six but I'm within 10
pounds of my fight weight like I I'm
confident and capable willing to throw
down at a moment's notice with a man
but if a woman gets mad I shut down I
just I don't know what to do and in a
couple instances of reference rather
than try to intervene or stop the other
woman or get in the way I tried to
control my wife instead I was like honey
you need to calm down you need to do
this and
I I didn't help her and she has
expressed to me that now she feels
unsafe
and I will do anything I can to save my
marriage and I I got to figure out how
to get over
my issues with women and be able to
stand up to a woman
that's the first time you ever said that
out loud
uh besides
yeah I just want to applaud you for
saying that out loud that's hard
thank you
that's hard
you're not a coward you're not weak okay
cool thank you
and if you've listened to the show for
more than five minutes I'm not always
accurate but I never lie okay
so
your mom abused you
that's trauma right
yeah are you are you do you acknowledge
that
I do okay
so trauma is
can be a couple of things
it can be what you experience which is
abuse
it can also be
what should have happened what you
should have received as a child as a kid
that an adult withheld from you
okay that makes sense
that means your dad is involved in this
too
your dad left you man
yeah and you got a little boy in there
wondering why dad did you leave me
with this woman that I don't really know
to go through this
and where's birth mom
she passed away when I was three okay he
remarried when I was almost six okay
and I'm just gonna make up a story here
that might or might not be right but it
wouldn't surprise me
if he went all in on your birth mom
and she died
and he didn't have a plan B
and his body told him
I we don't have a plan B but we're never
going to get hurt like that again
but he wanted companionship and he
wanted connection so he got remarried to
somebody and then he hit the road
you nailed it almost exactly he was
all in with my mother to the point of
uh working multiple jobs to afford a
lifestyle they couldn't really afford so
she could have everything they were
living in Hawaii and he was I mean all
the way down to not being a religious
man himself but never missed Sunday mass
because she was at about Catholic and
then when she passed it it broke him
yeah and so the man that raised me was
an alcoholic that worked on the road a
lot that's right
I need you to hear the layers here
mom dies at three
dead disappears in a bottle
dad disappears on the road dad gets
remarried to somebody who's abusive and
crazy
and Nico you got out
don't let anybody ever
ever
tell you that you're weak
whether you're not strong or you're a
wuss ever
and I don't care about your MMA record
okay
you got out
you hear what I'm saying
I did okay
now I think you're misguided and I'm
telling you that out of love okay okay
um
I've done a few things to a few events
with
um Jocko you know Jocko
I do the Navy SEAL guy is real tough
he's awesome he's a great guy behind
closed doors he's a great guy in front
of closed door he's a great guy and he's
doing some good stuff
former Navy SEAL
and I'll never forget this as long as I
live
in my training I didn't have a record at
all my training for years with mma's
before you could get fights every
weekend it was impossible to get fights
um
I left MMA training infinitely less of a
hot head
I haven't been in an altercation since
I just decided I'm never doing that
again because it wasn't the end result
wasn't worth it
and I'll never forget this interview
with Jaco where somebody was asking him
about it and if you don't know Jocko's
multi-time black belt in Jiu Jitsu he's
a former Navy SEAL he lifts weights 24 7
365 he eats like bricks and iron for
breakfast
um
and somebody asked him okay so you're
walking with your wife and kids down the
streets of San Diego and some crazy
person runs out and tries to start
something with you what do you do
and Jocko said
well I guess I would grab my wife's hand
and
we'd walk across the street and go down
the other sidewalk
and the guy said what
you wouldn't defend your wife's honor
and Jocko said something that will stay
with me for the rest of my life
he said
if it takes me beating up some
low life on the streets
to prove that I honor my wife
I have failed her in every other facet
of our relationship
that's not where you show honor
and then he went on to say there's a
handful of men on planet Earth that can
defeat me in hand-to-hand combat and
they all do it for a living they're all
professional fighters
and if somebody steps to me in a bar I
will buy them a drink and wish them well
because they're clearly having a worse
day than I am I have a pretty good life
and I remember one time getting into
something in my wife thinking I was
defending my wife and she uh she may be
my girlfriend at the time or just early
on in my wife
and she told me I feel less safe
when you do that
so I want to challenge you
given my my life story
listen to what Jacques to say
it may be if your wife's in an
altercation with another woman the
greatest smartest way you can love her
is to grab your wife's hand and get out
that throwing a punch at a woman or
defending yourself in front of women or
mouthing off at a woman is not the
greatest display of honor and integrity
and safety
the strongest thing to do is to take
your emotions and put them in your back
pocket and do the smart intelligent
thing it's going to allow you to wake up
the next day without somebody throwing a
bottle and smashing in the head that you
didn't see coming or waking up the next
day not in jail waking up next day with
a bunch of people filming what happened
and now you can't you're unemployable
because you beat up a theme you see what
I'm saying
yeah so
what happened in these situations that
you walked away from or you tried to get
your wife to settle down to where she
feels unsafe
so
uh the first one would have been
she was a couple months pregnant
and we were in Nevada visiting some
family and she was in the restroom and
there was a an old lady that was waiting
in line and got impatient and was
knocking on the door a bunch and her and
my wife had a
brief spat or whatever when my wife was
leaving the bathroom
and my mother-in-law was with my wife at
the time and I had been
elsewhere checking out the drink cooler
going to get my wife something to drink
her and the Mother-in-law headed
straight outside instead of coming over
to where I was so I went out to ask her
if she still wanted to drink
and we went back into the store and then
the old lady came up and started telling
my wife you know other people have
problems too and going off about
something and she got close enough to my
wife that it made my life very
uncomfortable and so my wife got real
loud and they were going back and forth
and I was just like dumbfounded that
this was even happening like
here's my wife having a borderline
yelling match with an old lady at a gas
station and so so Nico you're the one
that got put in an unsafe situation
what about the fact that I didn't defend
my pregnant wife
what in the world is your pregnant wife
doing getting in a fight with a old
woman who's
may have medical issues may have mental
health issues
may have some deranged sun in the car
with a gun why in the world is
this is like children you see what I'm
saying
and I felt very much that way at the
time you were your feelings were
accurate at the same time no I your
feelings were right I took her into that
situation to the gas station
she had headed outside I took her back
in there okay so yeah
okay so you messed up
you can get back in the car and be like
whoa thought we could talk that one out
not talking that one out then the whole
thing's over we're moving down the road
okay okay
I have asked my wife on occasion don't
get me in a situation that I'm gonna get
myself killed because I will
and she is my wife is as calm as they
come and she's like trust me if that
happens that would be because you're an
idiot not because not because of me
okay
your Valor
and value to your wife
is not in confronting old women in gas
stations
okay
yeah
when we talked about that situation and
the other one afterwards
because there was one other one
involving a nurse
at the hospital after the baby was born
and
again
uh
it was a verbal thing my wife was really
stressed out and the nurse rather than
suggesting things was telling her what
to do and my wife got all he did and
ended up
telling her you know you need to get out
of here I'll have you removed while this
was going on my wife was getting tense
rather than telling the nurse to go I
was telling my wife you need to calm
down you need to take some deep breaths
keep your blood pressure down okay and
let's back out of that situation for a
second
did y'all just have a new kid
yeah you know who thinks rationally in
those moments no humans on the planet
no one yeah no one
and so
there's got to be some Grace on both
sides
confronting a nurse in a hospital is
almost never The Right Move
and telling your wife you just had a
baby to quote unquote calm down that's
probably pretty dumb all right I
wouldn't say that and I regretted it
well and
asking your husband to beat up a nurse
in a that's dumb too you see what I'm
saying the whole thing is being able to
step back 30 000 foot after an emotional
interaction and say whoa that guy heated
I feel like we're having a
misunderstanding though John because she
never asked me to beat anybody up it was
more
when I asked her about what she expects
okay essentially in these situations she
wants me to get in between to be a
shield so that she has the option to
leave instead I try to put her in the
Box I try to control her and that's
where the problem is
I I feel safe enough with my wife that I
will tell her you need to calm down
versus some strange woman who's getting
emotional and I don't know what to do
about it that's the smart move
leave
oh okay okay
we can have the discussions we can have
the disagreements we can have the fights
and the frustrations when we're at home
and we're safe and no one's gonna hit us
over the head with a bottle
but In the Heat of the Moment Sometimes
the best thing to do is I need you to
leave
has she ever grabbed you by the arm and
walked you out of a place because you're
a hot head probably
um not
number did your MMA coach ever do that
um say shut me down
on more than one occasion exactly it
happens it's a smart move people who
love us and take care of us because
sometimes we get heated and emotional in
the in the moment
yeah I think the bigger conversation
that you'll need to have is this
when do you not feel safe
Nico
when your wife is standing eye to eye
nose to nose with another adult woman
jawing and yelling and people are back
and forth
you can say honey that makes me I've got
to get in the middle of that
please walk away
and she can tell you I don't feel safe
when someone's attacking her that's a
whole other conversation that's not
happening here
and more broadly speaking
whether this is related or not I don't
know man but whether it's related or not
your body understands
very deeply
that when somebody gets aggressive or in
your face particularly someone who
reminds your body of your stepmom I
don't want to paint that as all women
but as someone who reminds your body of
your stepmom
the safest thing to do is shut the
machine down shut it down
go to neutral back it down the whole
thing turn it off that's the safest bet
to get out of the situation
okay
and your your homework over the course
of your life this is an ongoing thing
is to number one make sure this sweet
little girl
always knows that Mom and Dad are in
control emotionally and physically
okay that y'all are safe
okay we're gonna break this cycle with
this young one
and see I'm I'm really glad you said
that because there is
an instant that was different than that
um my wife had a son from a previous
relationship who I've since adopted I
mean that is he's my boy
but there was an instant one incident
with a man and it basically involved
my son and his son were at a park and
the other guy's kid was being a jerk to
my kid my kid said stop the kid didn't
stop
and uh my wife who at the time was my
girlfriend like we'd been dating a
couple of days
um
went to talk to the other kid and
the dad got up in my wife's face and
started yelling at her and at the time
like I said girlfriend of a couple days
and I see a dude bigger than me yelling
at a woman smaller than me and I had no
issue getting between them and telling
him he needed to get the hell back
and but do you see the difference there
yeah it was a man no no no has nothing
to do with the gender I mean maybe it
does
but one of those situations or two of
those situations was escalated by your
wife
she could have got out of the bathroom
with an elderly woman and said hey I'm
sorry you're an older lady I'm sorry I
had to go you clearly have to go to I'm
sorry just walk away go home
that's different then
a big man coming at your wife in the
park in attack mode that's a totally
different proposition
and in your body it's starting to
conflate
aggression and frustration and all of it
just gets wound up
yes I would do the same thing if
someone's come after my wife I'm gonna
get between them there's no question
about that
and if my wife just needs to if we can
just walk out the door get in the car
I'm gonna walk out the door and get in
the car
and it's not because I'm a wimp but it's
not because it's because I'm smart and I
have honor that woven into my
relationship
as I was saying a minute ago you gotta
the rest of your life is going to be
dedicated to letting this little girl
know you're present you're not going to
get on the road you're not going to run
you're not going to turn to alcohol when
being a parent gets hard and make no
mistake Nico it'll get hard
and
when your body begins to seize up on you
and freeze on you and shut down on you
you're gonna feel it you're gonna feel
it and go
we used to not be safe and now we are
we used to not be safe
well now we are
and we're just gonna practice safety
when you don't feel safe when your
wife's dragging you into a fight with an
older woman in a gas station you are
right to say this is not smart for
either of us let's not do this I brought
you back inside I thought we could talk
it out I was stupid of me I'm sorry
you're a good man dude you're a good man
you've been through hell and back and
you got the scars and strength to prove
it
let's make moving forward about
connection let's make moving forward
about safety let's make moving forward
about teaching our body that we weren't
okay then but we're okay now
let's break this generational abuse and
alcohol let's stop it it stops with you
I'll walk with you the whole way my
brother give me a call anytime